The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I want to finish up
our little excursion into
searching and sorting, a very
important topic in computing.
How do you sort lists
or databases?
How do you search them?
And I want to finish
it up with hashing.
Hashing is how dictionaries
are implemented in Python.
And this leads to a
very efficient--
at least most of the
time-- search.
But it comes at the
cost of space.
So this is an example where one
can trade space for time.
So I want to start
with a simple
example to explain hashing.
And I'm going to begin by
assuming that what we're
hashing is a set of integers.
So we want to build a set of
integers and detect whether or
not a particular integer
is in that set.
And we want to do
that quickly.
So the basic idea is we're going
to take an integer--
call it i--
and we're going to hash it.
I'll tell you what that
means in a minute.
And what a hash function does
is it converts i to a
different integer, perhaps,
in some range.
So it, say, converts i to some
integer in the range 0 to k,
for some constant k.
We're going to then use
this integer to index
into a list of lists.
So each of these is
called a bucket.
And a bucket will itself
be a list.
So this together is
called a bucket.
We've already seen that we can
find the i-th element of a
list in constant time.
So when we ask whether some
integers in this set will hash
it, we'll go immediately to the
correct bucket, the bucket
associated with that integer.
And then we'll search the list
at that bucket to see if the
integer is there.
If this list is short enough,
it will be very efficient.
All, right I realize that's
very abstract.
But let's look at the code,
which will make
it much less abstract.
So the code starts with
something very ugly that I'll
apologize for.
But very soon, we'll see
how to get rid of that.
I'm using a global variable here
to say how many buckets
there are going to be.
And I've very arbitrarily
chosen 47.
I then have a function called
create, which uses this global
variable and creates a
list of lists, each
element of which is empty.
Because initially, we have
no elements in the set.
When I want to insert an element
in the set, I'll call
the function insert, which
will hash the element.
It doesn't actually even need
to use the global numBuckets
in this case, in fact.
And then append it to
the correct list.
So it calls this function
hashElem, which could hardly
be simpler.
It just takes the remainder, the
modulus of the element and
the number of buckets.
So that will give me a
value between 0 and
numBuckets minus 1.
It gives me one of the
list, and I'll just
insert it at the end.
When I want to check for
membership, you'll see it's
quite simple.
All I do is ask the question,
is i in the list associated
with the correct bucket?
Remove is a little bit more
complicated, but in fact, we
don't need to spend much
time looking at it now.
It's just some code.
And the only reason it's
complicated is Insert doesn't
look whether or not the element
is already there.
So it may occur multiple
times in the list.
So I would have to remove
each one of them.
People see the basic
structure of this?
Why a list of lists?
Why don't I just, say, have a
list of Booleans, where I hash
the integer, and it's true or
false, whether or not I've
seen it, depending upon the
value of that bucket?
Why can't I do that?
Somebody?
Well, what's the property
of this hash function?
The key issue here is
the hash function --
is many-to-one.
That is to say, an infinite
number of different integers
will hash to the same value.
Because after all, I have
a set in which I
can store any integer--
or any positive integer,
at least--
and there are only 47 buckets.
So it's pretty obvious that many
integers will hash to the
same bucket.
When two different elements hash
to the same bucket, we
have what is called
a collision.
There are lots of different
ways to handle collisions.
What I've shown you here is
probably the simplest way,
which is called linear
rehashing.
I'm not actually rehashing.
I'm just keeping a list.
Does that makes sense?
Yes, thank you for--
I'm glad somebody
has a question.
You have to ask loudly.
AUDIENCE: When you take
the modulus 47,
what does that return?
PROFESSOR: 0.
AUDIENCE: So hashElem
always returns 0?
PROFESSOR: Well, no, sorry.
It depends what I'm hashing.
Sorry, I thought if you
were saying that if I
asked 47 mod 47.
If I take 48 mod 47, I get 1.
If I take 49 mod 47--
it's the remainder.
Maybe I should have called
it just the remainder.
Look up.
I'm about to throw
something at you.
Ooh, I threw a curve ball.
OK.
What's the complexity here
of the membership test?
Kind of hard to analyze.
Roughly speaking, or exactly,
it will be the length of the
bucket, the size
of the bucket.
Now, I don't know how
many elements
will be in the bucket.
But what will this depend on?
It will depend upon the
number of buckets.
If I have a million buckets,
I'll get a lot fewer
collisions than if I
have two buckets.
So let's look at an
example here.
There's a small program
called test.
I said numBuckets to
47 in this case.
And then I'm going to create
it, create a set.
And then I'm going to put a
bunch of integers in it, then
a few more, just for fun,
including one very big
integer, just to show
that it works.
Then I'm going to show you
what the set looks like.
And in fact, what we'll do is
we'll stop it here and see
what we get.
So what we'll see here is, as
you would expect with that
number of buckets, each of the
small numbers hashes to a
separate thing.
That's just the way
remainder works.
Not surprisingly--
in fact, it would be
disappointing if 325 didn't
have the same value both
times I inserted it.
So we say we happen to have
one bucket that's got two
elements in it.
Happen to be the same.
But this very big number
happened to hash to the same
value of 30 as 34.
So here we have two
elements in it.
A good hash function has the
property that it will widely
disperse the values you hash.
So they end up in different
buckets, rather than some
stupid hash function that tends
to put everything in the
same bucket.
Now, let's see what happens if I
change the number of buckets
to, say, 3.
Well, not surprisingly, we get
some very big buckets, because
there are relatively
few choices.
So what we see here is we have
a genuine trade off between
time and space.
If the number of buckets is
large relative to the number
of elements that we insert in
the table, then looking at
whether or not an element in
it is roughly order one.
Because these lists will
be very short.
So we can actually look up
something in constant time if
we dedicate enough space
to the hash table.
If the hash table
is very small--
the reduction ad absurdium
case of one bucket--
then it's order n.
It's not constant time.
It's linear in the number
of elements.
Typically, when people use hash
tables, they make the
hash tables big enough that for
all intents and purposes,
you can assume that looking
something up is
constant time, order 1.
And that, in fact, is what
Python does with dictionaries.
It hashes the keys and chooses
a big enough table so that
looking up whether or not
something is in a dictionary
can be done in constant time.
If it then notices that the
table is too small, because
you've ended up putting a lot
of elements in it, it just
re-does it and gets
a bigger table.
So hashing is an extremely
powerful technique.
And it's used all the time for
quite complicated things.
Now is it useful here only when
we want to store ints?
No.
It would be kind of bad
if that were the case.
In fact, any kind of immutable
object can be hashed.
Now, you may have wondered
why the keys in
dicts have to be immutable.
And that's so that they
can be hashed.
Why does it have to
be immutable?
Well, imagine that you
used a list as a key.
You'd hash it when you put the
list in the hash table.
But then you might mutate it,
and the next time you hashed
it, you'd get a different value,
and so you wouldn't be
able to find it again.
So you need it to be a kind of
object, where every time you
apply the hash function,
you get the same value.
I don't need to show you
that this works.
You'll just believe
me, I'm sure.
Let's look at a slightly more
complicated hash function.
Here, I want to hash something
that could be
either an int or a string.
So I first check and
see if it's an int.
If so, I'll set the
value to be e.
Then down at the bottom, I'll do
the modulus operator again.
But if it's a string,
I'm going to first
convert e to an int.
And this is basically the trick
that people typically
use when they're doing hashing,
is they convert
whatever thing they have,
to some integer.
People do this with all
sorts of things.
For example, this is the way
airport security systems today
do face recognition.
They hash every picture of a
face to an integer, and then
look it up.
So we can see it here.
The way I'm doing it--
and the details
don't very much matter--
is I'm going to do it a
character at a time, do a
shift ord of C, takes the
ASCII, the internal
representation bits
of each character.
And again, I don't care
if you understand how
the code works here.
What I just want you to see is
that it's not very long.
And in, fact it's typically
fairly simple to hash almost
any kind of an object.
Because deep down, we know
that every object is
represented by some string of
bits in the computer's memory.
And we can always convert a
string of bits to an integer.
All right, so that's hashing, a
very powerful and extremely
useful technique.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
you're returning something,
will you always find the
remainder, or can you
use [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: There are many
different ways of doing hash.
All the hash function has to
do is convert its argument
into an integer in some way or
another within a fixed range.
It happens to be that remainder
is a very simple way
to do that and is often used.
There's a whole theory
about hash functions.
You can read about them in
gory detail on Wikipedia.
The math can actually be quite
complicated, and there's no
real need to understand it.
I typically do something like
dividing by a prime number,
which is known to have
good properties.
But, again, you can get carried
away with this.
And it's usually not worth the
trouble, unless you're very
deeply involved in something.
OK?
And then I've got another
program that does this, but
again, I don't think much
would be served by
running it for you.
Any questions about hashing?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So does this only
work because you said
[INAUDIBLE]
Python treats lists
in a certain way?
You said other languages, you
can't have this constant time
list search.
So how would hashing work?
PROFESSOR: So the question is
that, because Python gives us
constant-time looking up for
lists is the key to making
this work --
every programming language
I know has some
concept that's similar.
In, say, C, it's not a list,
but it's an array.
And so in C, you would use
array for this purpose?
In Java, you would use the
arrays for this purpose?
But yes, you can do this in
any programming language,
because every reasonable
programming language has some
way to create the equivalent
of a list, in which you can
get a particular index
in constant time.
So it's a universally
useful technique.
Good question.
Anything else?
If not, we're about to abandon
searching and sorting, and in
fact, abandon algorithms
in general for a while.
Bounced right off his hands.
I will not sign you to
a baseball contract.
Pardon?
Yes, I threw him
a Butterfinger?
Oh, it's terrible.
Boy, your jokes are
worse than mine.
I now want to move
on to the last--
go back to Python, away from
algorithms, away from computer
science in general, and talk
about the last three major
linguistic concepts in Python,
exceptions, classes, and then
later iterators.
Let's start with exceptions,
because we've already seen
them, and they're
pretty simple.
Exceptions are everywhere
in Python.
And we've certainly seen
plenty of them
all semester already.
We get them if we set some
list to, say [1,2]
and then I asked for a test of
12, I get an index error.
This is an exception.
We've got exceptions when we've
tried to convert things
to incorrect types.
So if I go into test, I'll
get a type error.
Anything that ends in the word
"error" is a built-in kind of
exception in Python.
We've got them when we
accessed, nonexistent
variables, a name error.
So there are a whole bunch
of these things.
In each of these cases--
here, I'm just kind of playing
around in Python.
And it printed an error message,
and it stopped.
These kind of exceptions are
called unhandled exceptions,
where they cause the program
to effectively crash.
The program just
stops running.
And I suspect that some of you
have written programs in which
this has happened.
In fact, is there anybody here
who has not written a program
that crashed because of an
unhandled exception?
Good.
For those of you watching
on TV, no hands went up.
Almost every day, I write a
program that crashes because
of an unhandled exception.
On the other hand, once my
program is debugged--
once your program is
debugged-- this
should never happen.
Because there are mechanisms
in Python for handling
exceptions.
And in fact, as we'll see, it's
a perfectly valid flow of
control concept.
You will sometimes write
programs that are intended to
raise exceptions.
And then you'll catch the
exception and do something
useful with it.
The way we use exceptions
is in something called a
try-except block.
So you write the word "try," and
then you have some code,
and then "except," and
then some more code.
What the interpreter does is it
starts executing this code.
If it gets through this code
without raising any kind of an
exception, it jumps to the code
following the except block.
On the other hand, if an
exception gets raised here, it
immediately stops executing
this code and jumps to the
start of this code, the code
associated with the except,
and executes that.
And, then when it finishes this,
it again goes to the
code following the except.
Just like an if, you can
nest these things.
It's just a control concept.
It's nothing more.
Let's look at an example.
So here's readVal.
This is a function.
It's a polymorphic function.
Its first argument is
of type 'type'.
Remember--
and you'll hear me say this a
1,000 more times at least--
in Python, everything is an
object and can be manipulated
by the program.
It's one of the beauties
of Python.
It's something that's not true
in many programming languages.
So types are objects, just
like ints or floats.
So the first argument to
readVal is a type.
And then there are two strings,
the request message
and the error message.
It then sets a local variable,
numTries, to 0.
And while numTries is less than
4, it sets val equal to
raw input, printing the
request message.
And then it tries to convert val
to valType, whatever that
happens to be.
And if it succeeds,
it returns it.
On the other hand, if during
this attempt to convert it an
exception is raised--
for example, the user is asked
to input an integer, and they
type in the letter b, which
can't be converted to an int--
then a type error exception
will be raised, or a value
error exception.
And if a value error exception
is raised, it prints the error
message, increases numTries by
1, and goes back to the top of
the y loop.
If it goes through this y loop
too many times, it leaves,
raising the type error with the
message that the argument
"numTries
exceeded." All right.
Let's run this and
see what happens.
Every once in a while,
funny things happen.
When that happens, somehow,
clicking in this window, and
then clicking back in
that window tends to
make it work again.
This is a bug in Python.
So it's now asked me
to enter an int.
If I enter an int, everything
is good.
It just prints it.
On the other hand, if I run it,
and I enter the letter A,
it will give me another
chance.
And now I can enter an
int, and it's happy.
All right.
Now, suppose I am unhappy with
the fact that if four times in
a row I've failed to enter an
int, something bad happens.
It comes back, and it
raises an exception.
Well, I can catch that in the
code that calls readVal.
So here at the top level, I'm
going to try readVal.
And then I'm going to say,
except if a type error is
raised, print the argument
returned by that exception.
So this is what's called the
handler for the exception.
And so I don't have to crash
when the exception is raised.
But I can actually deal with it
and do something sensible.
If following the word "except,"
as you see over
there, I have not listed any
exception names, then I'll go
to the except clause
for all exceptions.
Doesn't matter what
the exception is.
I will go there.
So I can write code that
captures any exception.
OK.
Usually, that's not as good a
thing, because it shows that I
did not anticipate what the
exception might be.
But you can see that
this is a pretty
powerful programming paradigm.
I can write this fairly compact
readVal function
that's pretty robust.
It's polymorphic, it can take
in what the error messages
are, and it can try as
many times as I want.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] after
type error [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: PROFESSOR: You'll note
that when I raised the
exception type error after it, I
had an open [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
a string.
So what this basically says is
that an exception can have
associated with it a
set of arguments,
a sequence of arguments.
And I've just chosen to call the
first of the arguments s,
so that I could then print it.
So this is a fairly common
paradigm, that you associate a
message with an exception,
explaining the exception.
Since after all, type error is
not all that meaningful.
And this tells me why it
was raised, that I
tried too many times.
OK, does it make sense?
Anything else?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
before you said [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well, what we'll see
when I execute something
like assert false, it's actually
raising an exception.
It's raising an assertion
error exception.
And so I can actually catch that
and do something with it.
I've been using these
asserts just
basically to stop the program.
But we've also seen that
sometimes in functions, we use
assertions to check the types
of the arguments.
But if you don't catch that
exception, then the program
crashes with the wrong
arguments, without doing
anything useful.
Because that's just an
exception, I can catch it, and
then do something useful.
So it's, again, just
an example of that.
We're going to try your
hands once more.
I'll throw you a different
kind of candy.
And this time he caught it.
Two for two.
Very powerful.
A very useful mechanism.
You can use them for sort
of catching errors,
as we've done here.
They are frequently used in
situations where you are
getting input from a user.
So for example, if you were
writing a text editor, and you
wanted to open up a file, and
you typed in the file name,
and it didn't exist, you would
in Python get an error message
when you try to open
that file.
It would raise an exception,
"File Not Found," basically,
which you could then catch, and
then print to the user a
useful error message saying,
"File Not Found."
Similarly, if you try and write
to a file that already
exists, you can get an exception
saying, do you
really want to overwrite
this file?
And ask the user.
So it's very commonly
used in a lot of
programs as a mechanism.
And now, as we go on and see
more and more code, you'll see
that I'm going to start using
exceptions fairly frequently
as a flow of control
mechanism.
It makes certain kinds of
code easier to write.
All right.
That's all I have to say
about exceptions.
Simple but useful mechanism.
Now, on to something
that's even more
useful, but not so simple.
It is probably the
distinguishing thing, not only
in Python, but in
a whole class of
modern programming languages.
And that's the notion
of a class.
I'm not going to finish
it today.
I'm barely going to scratch
the surface of it today.
But we're going to start leading
up and I will pretty
much finish it on Thursday.
We've already seen the notion of
a module, which has been a
collection of related
functions.
So, for example, we've seen code
that includes something
like import math.
And that provided me
with access to
functions like math.log.
What the module mechanism does
in the import mechanism, it
makes it convenient
to import a lot of
related things at once.
And then we use this dot
notation to disambiguate, to
tell us, well, which log.
Typically, there's probably
only one log function.
But certainly, you might imagine
that set.member and
table.member would
be different, and
that both might exist.
And as we've said before, the
dot notation avoids conflicts
by disambiguating.
OK.
That's a module.
What a class is, it is like a
module, but it's not just a
collection of functions.
A class is a collection of data
and functions, functions
that operate on that data.
They are bound together, so that
you can pass an object
from one part of a program
to another.
And the part of the program
to which you pass it
automatically gets access to the
functions associated with
that type of object.
And this is really the key
to what people call
object-oriented programming,
a very popular buzzword.
So we've already seen that kind
of thing, where if we
pass a list from one function
to another, we can write
something like L.append,
some value.
The data and functions
associated with an object are
called that object's
attributes.
So you can think of this as a
way to associate attributes
with objects.
Now, I've been talking about
data and functions as if
they're different
kinds of things.
In fact, they're not really,
because they're just objects.
In Python, everything is an
object, including, as we'll
see on Thursday, the class
itself is an object.
When people talk about objects
and object-oriented
programming, they often use a
message passing metaphor.
And I want to emphasize it's
nothing more than a metaphor.
And I almost hesitate to bring
it up, because it makes it all
sound more complicated
than it is.
But you will see this phrase
in the literature.
People will use it.
So you need to know
what it is.
The basic metaphor is that when
I write something like
L.append, I am passing the
message append e to the object
L. And then there's a mechanism
for looking up what
that object means, what
that message means.
And then the object, L, executes
that message, and
does something.
So, for example, if I had a
class called Circle, I might
pass the object C --
the message area, which would
cause this object to return
the area of its own area, the
area of the circle that is
that object.
Again, nothing dramatic
going on here.
If you just think of this as
a fancy way of writing
functions, you'll be
absolutely correct.
But I did think you should
hear about this metaphor.
I add by the way --
should have--
I've been using the word...
Method is a function associated
with an object.
So in this case, the method area
is associated with the
object C. And purists would say,
always refer to append as
a method, rather than a
function, because we use the
dot notation to get to it, and
it's always associated with
some object of type list.
Now, just as data can have
types, objects, as we know,
have types.
What a class is is it's a
collection of objects with
identical characteristics
that form a type.
So we can use classes to
introduce new types into the
programming environment.
So as you think about
existing things--
now, I won't put that up,
because it will disappear
behind the screen.
We've looked at things
like lists and dict.
What these are are
built-in classes.
They happen to be classes that
are so useful that somebody
decided they should be part of
the language, they should have
efficient implementations,
they should be built-in,
people shouldn't have to
reimplement them themselves.
And in fact, there are a whole
bunch of interesting built-in
classes in Python.
And there are a whole bunch of
libraries of classes you can
bring in-- and we'll look
at many of those--
that extend it.
And that's the beauty of
the class mechanism.
It lets you add new types to
the language that are every
bit as easy to use as
the built-in types.
So in effect, the language can
be extended to add new and
useful types.
And we'll look at several
examples of
that starting on Thursday.